There is a lot of unnecessary
variation of treatment decisions,
especially in the Western world.
You need to get in the front seat
with your doctor and start
sharing decisions on where to go.
Four questions, simple questions.
Consider them your new toolbox to help us.
Is this really necessary?
What are the risks?
Are there other options?
And what happens if I don't do anything?
Ask them when your doctor
wants to send you to an MRI,
when he prescribes antibiotics,
or suggests an operation.
What we know from research
is that one out of five of you,
20 percent, will change your
opinion on what to do.
And by doing that, you will
not only have made your life
a whole lot easier
and probably even better.
But the whole healthcare sector
will have benefited from your decision.